the latest on Charlottesville the latest
on ante for the latest on the alt-right
and people tearing down Confederate
memorials for no apparent reason I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
another day another world full of
terribleness and we will discuss all of
it from left to right and right to left
and all the things in between but before
we get to any of that first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
MVM t so MVM T watches was founded on
the belief that you should be able get a
really nice watch really clean looking
watch and not break the bank okay I love
my mbm to watch so much I wear it every
single day the folks at the studio can
testify to this it is a fantastic watch
it is really really nice and my wife
actually needed to watch the other day
and so I picked up another watch from
MVM t for her rose gold beautiful watch
he's been getting compliments on it all
week not only that but these are more
expensive than things that you get at
the store a watch like this would
normally cost a couple hundred bucks
across like 100 over it over at MVM t
all of these watches are quality they
they keep good time which is obviously
the first necessity they are minimalist
the well-designed they don't break
they're really really nice movement
watches start at just 95 bucks at a
department store sometimes you're
looking at 400 to 500 dollars for their
upper end watches movement figured out
that by selling online they can cut out
the middleman and lower the price and it
is really nice stuff over 1 million
watches sold in over 160 countries right
now if you go to MVM t.com slash capiro
MVM t.com slash capiro you get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns if you don't like it MVM
t-dot-com slash Shapiro as I say I wear
this watch everywhere you can see the
testimony of me on Capitol Hill I'm
wearing my MVM t watch because I like
this watch so much and you should have
one too
MVM t comm / apparel get 15% off again
use that slash Shapiro they know that we
sent you as well okay so I just want to
remind everyone of how terrible what
happened in Charlotte all over the
weekend was there was some footage that
came out yesterday that we weren't able
to show on the show cuz it came out
later here is here's drone footage of
what happened in Charlottesville when
this 20 year old piece-of-crap decided
to drive his car into a crowd of anti
neo-nazi anti can't I kneel Confederate
anti alt-right protesters
you can see it from the staff right and
see this red car being pushed into the
crowd and people being killed one person
died from this and another 19 were
injured pretty frightening and
horrifying and then of course the car
reversed itself and drove off in the
other direction just horrifying stuff
okay so with that in the background
we're going to get to a lot today I want
to talk about President Trump's new
response yesterday he finally came out
and gave a speech that he should have
given unsanded afterward which were not
helpful to him we're going to talk about
the left which has lost its mind so the
left always is going to turn this into a
referendum on the entire right it
doesn't matter the people like me have
been the lead antagonist of the
alt-right for well over a year they were
always going to turn this into some sort
of club that they could wield against
the entire right and against the Trump
administration in particular claiming
that everyone in the Trump
administration must be smeared with this
broad brush of all right ISM and racism
and bigotry and that is really nasty and
actually it's exacerbating the problems
what you're seeing is two sides as I
spoke about yesterday and keifa on the
one side and the alt-right on the other
side and the mainstream left focus on
the alt-right and willingness to adhere
to an FIFA and the mainstream rights
willingness to ignore the outright and
their willingness to go after and keifa
alone means that both the alt-right in
antifa will grow okay we're now in a
self-perpetuating cycle where auntie
Fudd says we have to stop the fascists
and then they act violently and the
right says well we're going to side with
anybody who acts violently the way these
antiva people are the alt-right must not
be that bad which of course leads the
left to say well and people must not be
that bad because the alt-right
represents a broad swath of the right
and therefore we have to fight them
tooth and nail because hitler's around
the corner and they just keep reinsuring
the importance of one another and you
can see it from the left so the left's
activities in the aftermath of Charlotte
still have been absolutely egregious not
just the stuff they're saying the stuff
that there's it'll start the stuff
they're saying joy read over at MSNBC
she came out yesterday and she said
white nationalists are everywhere
they're behind your bed they're under
there behind your curtains
they're inside your closets and they're
all over the White House here's Joey
Reed making this case what is the
alt-right it's a dressed-up term for
white nationalism they call
the white identitarian ISM they say that
though tribalism that's sort of inherent
in the human spirit ought to be also
applied to white people that is who is
in his government Sebastien Gorka who
wore the metal the Vitesse here and a
Nazi organization being paid by the
taxpayer in the government of Donald
Trump the former Publius des blogger
Michael Anton in the government he is
surrounded by these people
it isn't both thought he's in the white
house they're in the white house with
him okay so the two people that you
mentioned are particularly bad example
Sebastien Gorka is not anti-semitic you
know the stories about him hanging out
with the far-right in Hungary there's
some truth to him hanging out with the
far-right in Hungary but there's no
evidence of his anti-semitism per se and
in the attempts to to link the metal
that he's been wearing around to Nazism
are really overblown there was a whole
article in that debunked the debunk the
article in the foreword I think it's
from the Atlantic that's amongst a lot
of this stuff so the gore because a bad
example and Michael Anton as much as I
dislike Michael Anton's writing and
think his flight 93 election essay was
garbage he is not a white nationalist
and so she's picking bad examples it
just demonstrates have left is tempted
to use the alt-right brush to paint
everyone rich Lowry who's sitting there
actually went on to chide Roy read for
doing exactly that and it's just it's
just foolish of the left to do this
because the more they do this the more
they push more people into the arms of
the alt-right a lot of people say well
if the alright is people like Michael
Anton in Sebastian Lorca I guess maybe
I'm alright
no you're not because those guys aren't
really alright ok the alt-right is
Richard Spencer Jared Taylor they're a
bunch of popularizers who have tried to
mainstream it by changing the definition
and the left is helping out in that
quest meanwhile you see the black lives
matter co-founder coming out and saying
that hate speech is not protected by the
First Amendment this is an actual threat
to the First Amendment of the United
States we saw yesterday Texas A&M
cancelled some sort of rally the some
white nationalist rally the under threat
of violence this is scary okay it's not
just scary cuz they're white
supremacists but it's scary because free
speech is right that all of us have even
the people who I think are garbage and
have terrible terrible views here's
black lives matter saying that if Tate
speech then it's not protected by the
First Amendment eminently untrue white
nationalists are actually fighting to
take away people's rights
black lives matter and groups like black
lives matter are fighting for equality
and hate speech which is what we're
seeing coming out of white nationalist
groups is not protected on the First
Amendment right and so I think that's
important that we really delineate
what's happening right now it's not
number one okay hate speech is of course
protected by the First Amendment and
when it comes to BLM trying to claim
that you know only one side is
promulgating hate speech I mean there
are there videos of people at BLM
rallies shouting pigs eat pigs in a
blanket fry them like bacon I talking
about cops okay you remember that it was
a guy who's very sympathetic to the
means and motives of BLM who shot a
bunch of cops in Dallas a year and a
half ago
I'm not saying BLM is to blame for that
I am saying that BLM is program is
hardly is hardly a nothing okay it's
hardly just we're trying to defend laws
and they've been incredibly anti cop
they've incentivize people in Ferguson
in Baltimore to riot and yet they say
that all of their enemies must be shut
down this is the danger point okay we're
reaching the danger point where people
on the Left say that the alt-right has
to be legitimately shut down not for
violence but because of what they say
and people on the all right say the
people on the left like an Tifa a
representative of the entire lapsed okay
we're really at a Vimal republic point
where you're seeing battles in the
streets and they've been going on for
months you're seeing the left exacerbate
this so that i understand that the media
is all of their sympathy is with the
left here because they think that an
Tifa is not that bad many of them they
think Antiqua is just anti-fascist
that's not just when mpa is the
communist the anarchist group that has
protested normal conservatives normal
Republicans in Portland Peter Bernard
white usually despised wrote a great
piece over at the Atlantic talking about
what n FIFA has done in cities like
Portland where just a normal group of
Republicans wanted to march in their
Rose Parade and the entire Rose Parade
had to be canceled because Han Tifa was
threatening okay so you've got a bunch
of violent people in the streets from
Antigua and among violent people from
the all right sometimes in response like
in Sacramento and sometimes as in
Charlottesville it's unclear who's
actually starting the violence we just
don't know yet but it's not getting
better when the left cheers on people
who are moving outside the modes of law
in order to enact their suppose an
agenda so here's some video yesterday
this happened over in Durham North
Carolina and here's a picture here's
of protestors toppling Confederate
soldiers monument you can see how this
is working
[Applause]
the toppling the monument destroying the
monument and then cheering like they've
done something grand and glorious and
then kicking the statue because ma I
broke my toe fighting racism the statue
was dedicated in 1924 authorities
greased the statue with cooking spray to
help make it harder to Klimt and they
stood around while they well this
happened where the cops for all of us
okay so the people United will never be
defeated its divided guys I mean if
you're going to get your chance get it
right but then they're all standing
around there's video of these people
jumping on top of the statue and kicking
the statute congratulations you ended
racism by tearing down a Confederate
statue nobody knew about or cared about
and was erected in 1924 I'm sure that
you didn't impose in the alt-right in
any way by doing this sort of thing by
by vandalizing property again there's a
case to be made and I've said this
before I certainly see the case for
taking Confederate monuments and moving
them into into museums moving them off
of public property I see the case for
that I don't see the case for destroying
it this looks like you know it's not
like Isis because these people aren't
Isis but there's a there's a an attempt
in the human soul to to rip away history
that you don't like supposedly because
you're going to fix the future but
that's not the case I mean honestly you
know I live as a Jew I live in a world
where our events still exist in Germany
I want that to exist in Germany I want
people to visit it I want people to know
that the threat of Auschwitz is still a
thing and that people should be aware of
that I think I fully understand why a
lot of black folks and a lot of white
folks would like to see Confederate
monuments taken away because it's a
reminder of an era when slavery was was
fought and defended at the same time you
have to acknowledge that a lot of the
people who had grant a
great-grandfather's who fought for the
Confederacy were not fighting for
slavery there are a lot of Confederates
who are fighting because they thought
that the north was encroaching on
southern states right okay I understand
that this is an historic is historically
accurate but may not may not be popular
the fact is that civil war was over
slavery but it was also over states
rights was over both of those things and
to pretend that there's only over one of
those things is to neglect the actual
history of the situation because the
fact is that even when the North went
into the Civil War it was
meaning to abolish slavery the
Emancipation Proclamation only happened
a couple of years into the Civil War it
was over slavery but it was over more
than that that does not justify the
Confederacy of course thank God the
Confederacy lost that is a wonderful
thing the Confederacy lost the rebels
should have lost the people who fought
to divide the country so they could
preserve slavery we're doing something
evil okay but to pretend that they're to
pretend that people who have Confederate
ancestors when they take Confederate
monuments are immediately think of
enslaving black people is just not true
and it's not accurate at least for the
vast majority of them tearing down
statues like this again we have a rule
of law in this country you want to do
this vote for people who are going to
remove the memorial vote for people who
are going to remove the memorial don't
just destroy things but I think this
what we're seeing here is actually part
of the same movement that wants to chip
Woodrow Wilson's name off buildings at
Princeton and wants to tear down statues
of Thomas Jefferson and that's a very
dangerous ideology and then beyond that
the violence that you're seeing here the
vandalism that you're seeing where are
the cops tearing down monuments in
breaking the law to do so we have a
democracy we have a republic and the
mayors of Lexington in Baltimore they're
removing Confederate monuments their
elected officials they can do that this
idea that you're going to go around
tearing down monuments and that this is
somehow similar to tearing down
monuments of saddam hussein in the
aftermath of saddam hussein's fall is
just inane it's just innate and all its
doing is embolden the alt-right which is
going to a lot of people and saying look
at these vandals these people who have
no respect for America's history because
yes
the Confederacy was a dark part but a
part of America's history and to pretend
that it wasn't is historically ignorant
you're embolden ilan the all right this
sort of behavior is not purposeful this
sort of behavior is not helpful you want
to protest against the alright by all
means do it your honor protests racism
by all means do it tearing down public
property is not the way to do this all
you're doing is driving people against
you and then it's driving again this is
this cycle of nastiness you know that
these examples go on and on yesterday
over at in New York a bunch of
protesters protesting at Trump Tower
because they didn't like Trump
statements over charlotte's though fine
fare but then there's this video of this
woman screaming at the cops for no
apparent reason even though we're doing
what we were done
your eyes weak because you know you're
wrong cuz you think you're a man you can
roll your eyes on a young woman roll
your eyes your show doesn't protect you
and just what is a LIFO person screaming
at people who are trying to protect the
President of the United States at Trump
Tower and saying that they are they are
the bad guys again none of this is
helpful to the anti-racist cause none of
this is helpful to the coming together
of Americans none of it is helpful on
the left is getting worse okay because I
think that now the left is celebrating
the punching of Nazis look at look at
the coverage of Charlottesville I
pointed out yesterday I open with all of
the video from Charlottesville and I
pointed out there are a lot of violent
people on the left there
Cheryl gage Solberg who is there from
the New York Times said as much and now
what you're seeing is whitewashing of an
tyfa in order to go after the all right
I don't see why you have to whitewash
one in order to go after the other I
went after the all right pretty hard
yesterday I will continue to go after
them hard I think they're disgusting
movement and I think that a lot of
people have been seduced into believing
they're not as disgusting as they are
but that does not excuse violence it
does not excuse vandalism it does not
excuse abusing police officers none of
this is worthwhile none of this is
worthwhile unfortunately it's all
getting worse I want to talk about
President Trump's response to all of
this but before I do I first want to say
thank you so our sponsor over at USC CA
so you would do anything to protect your
family and keep them safe of course and
so what a guy named Gary gross he was
the he was just in his house and two
intruders broke into his Cincinnati home
this last week according to ABC News his
wife and infant son were sleeping in a
back room Gary grabbed a hammer and
confronted the strange men in the
following struggle out number two two
one Gary retrieved his gun he shot the
men before they could endanger his
family's lives he was lucky that he was
prepared when he decided to make that
life-altering decision but when you are
facing an unexpected threat you don't
want to have to think about the plan
you're going to come up with you don't
have time to think about that and that's
why it's important to have you SEC air
by your side to prepare you for the
unthinkable go to defend my family now
calm and can see the world-class
training and resources their
self-defense training and resources and
they also have invaluable self-defense
coverage so in case you actually have to
shoot somebody you know one be stuck in
the court system for three years paying
your own legal bills the u.s. ECA helps
you out with all of that defend my
family now.com defend my family now calm
n right now when you activate your bonus
you activate your membership you get a
free entry to win a gun today so you can
be prepared to defend yourself and your
loved ones defend my family now calm
let's defend my family now calm so go
over and check that out to defend
yourself from an increasingly violent
world and it's getting scary out there
okay so president Trump decides that he
is going to that he is going to finally
change his statement he made on Saturday
as you recall Rhonda the President of
the United States made a statement on
Saturday in which he said that there was
violence and bigotry on all sides all
sides and he didn't specifically single
out the alt-right he didn't single out
the Nazis he didn't sink without any of
that and and the result of that was that
there was a lot of blowback and I think
right blowback I think it was correct to
have blowback I think President Trump
didn't do enough to disassociate himself
from the alt-right which he'd sort of
been winking at there was a report
yesterday that Steve Bannon had been
telling him over the weekend Steve Danon
who is his White House chief strategist
I got a guy know well former head of
Breitbart a man who said that he was
happy that he had turned Breitbart into
basically a forum for the alt-right a
guy who helps prop up figures like Milo
who were popularizing the alt right and
and so Trump didn't say anything and
apparently was very angry that he had to
go out and make a statement yesterday so
let's reenact yesterday with President
Trump so president Trump starts off the
day by going after the head of Merck so
Merck is a major pharmaceutical company
the CEO and Kenneth Fraser was on the
CEO of Merck and he was on president
Trump's manufacturing board after Trump
didn't come out strongly enough in his
opinion and condemned the outright and
white nationalism to white supremacism
he quit the board and from when to out
and tweeted remember this before he's
made any overt statement with regard to
the alt writer the KKK or anything he
tweeted Merck pharma is a leader in
higher and higher drug pirate prices
while at the same time taking jobs out
of the US bring jobs back and lower
prices so to leads off yesterday and
people like really this is where you're
putting your focus you're putting your
focus on the Merck head everybody thinks
that you need to come out and condemn
the alt-right everybody thinks you need
to come out and condemn white
supremacism if you want to condemn a
thief at the same time that would be
nice if you want to do all those things
you can do those things and instead he's
tweeting about Merck so finally
yesterday afternoon right about the time
that we were finishing filming the show
Trump gave a statement and here was
Trump's statement about racism and
finally condemning me all
writer and groups associated with
y'alright by name racism is evil and
those who cause violence in its name are
criminals and thugs including the KKK
neo-nazis white supremacist and other
hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as Americans we
are a nation founded on the truth that
all of us are created equal
we are equal in the eyes of our Creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal under our Constitution those who
spread violence in the name of bigotry
strike at the very core of America two
days ago a young American woman Heather
Hare was tragically killed her death
fills us with grief and we send her
family our thoughts our prayers and our
love okay good good for Trump for saying
this right this is what everybody wanted
him to say she just had 48 hours earlier
the long delay let a lot of give a lot
of credence a lot of the groups that
were claiming that Trump was on their
side you remember I read yesterday the
the Nazi out with the daily stormer
coming out and praising from for not
going too hard on the white nationalist
yesterday he blasts them and then what's
interesting is that okay what's the
fallout so that 48-hour gap creates a
series of alt-right people who go out
and say well Trump is really sort of
defending us isn't it you know his
silence means something to us and a
bunch of people I'm left saying his
silence mean something obviously to the
alright and then Trump says this and you
know he condemns them and the OLT rights
response is well he didn't really mean
it right like now he really didn't mean
it because he's coming out he's doing
this after pressure so according to
Olivia nosey who is a reporter I believe
for Politico she says Richard Spencer
doesn't think president Trump condemns
his movement today he called it kumbaya
nonsense and said Trump didn't mean it
only - who cares about that right maybe
Richard Spencer is just wrong Trump does
mean it and it's great that Trump did it
and good okay but then five minutes
after the speech you know a few minutes
after the speech Trump goes right back
on Twitter and is he going after the is
he going after the is he going after the
alright on Twitter is he retweeting his
own speech about racism no he's going
back
after the mirth guy he decides that it
is important that he must go after the
Merc guy again so he tweets again about
the Merc guy you know going after him
because he said he's a bad guy then he
goes on Twitter after that and he
decides that it is necessary to tweet
about the media so here is what he
tweeted he tweeted quote made additional
remarks on charlottesville and realized
once again that the fake news media will
never be satisfied truly bad people this
is just not smart it's not smart and
it's not moral okay the reason that you
should make that additional statement on
charlottesville is because the first one
was insufficient it was morally
insufficient you have to condemn the bad
guys what Trump sounds like he's saying
here ok if I were just to read this as a
layman when it sounds like he's saying
is that the reason that he made the
remarks in the first place is because
the fake news media we're pushing him to
do so and then they wouldn't accept him
saying what he was saying in other words
he was fine with not saying anything
additional this of course lends a lot of
credence to the stuff that Spencer was
saying that really the only reason that
Trump was doing this is because he was
pressured but deep down in the cockles
of his heart he really didn't want to
condemn me all right he really didn't
want to condemn the white supremacist
mr. Trump President Trump I don't think
that you're racist I don't think you're
a white supremacist I don't think you're
an alt writer please stop making moves
that are that are that are even open to
question okay this is so obvious and
this is so easy and when you blame the
fake news media for being mean to you
because you made a bad statement on
Saturday by the way the reports are that
there was a second statement that he had
in front of him on Saturday that was
exactly the same as the statement he
made yesterday and he went off cup
because he didn't actually want to
discuss the white supremacy on Saturday
right there was that report that came
out yesterday okay it's not good stuff
the President of the United States
agenda is determined by the president
actually being strong enough of will
being strong enough morally to stand up
against bad people and the idea that he
is going to sort of bend over backwards
to appease this this and this all right
movement is really gross I mean it's
it's such a problem this another example
right yes sir last night from the
president decides that it is important
to tweet a couple of things and he
tweets he tweets this is this morning he
retweeted at 4:40 a.m. this is his meme
and the mean says fake news can't stop
the Trump train and then it's a picture
of the
train hitting reporter with the CNN logo
over it now we've already had Trump do
this right I mean Trump already did the
thing with the with him tackling the
meme from the alt-right of him tackling
the the CNN logo had in the entire world
going nuts but this is three days after
a car hit anti all tripe protesters and
now he's tweeting out a picture of a
train
hitting CNN okay it's just not smart
it's just not smart and the account he
tweeted from apparently is an all right
account okay yesterday last night he
tweets out an account guess the guy's
name is Jack cassabi ACK you'll remember
him from such hits as storming the stage
the Julius Caesar production in Central
Park
he's an alt right friendly figure and
inject asabi Ike was also a pizza gate
promulgator and he tweeted something out
about how there were 35 people who were
shot in Chicago over the weekend why no
one wise known paying attention to that
and Trump elite retweeted it now if
Trump wants to say listen there's
killings all over the country a lot
there are a lot of things that we need
to do to stop them that's one thing but
retweeting people who are sort of part
of the the alt-right alt-right friendly
base it does not help his case that he's
trying to separate off from this group
and he should be separating off from
this group okay it's an immoral group
it's an immoral group and it's not that
everyone who likes means everyone who
tweets means as a member of the
alt-right I discussed this yesterday but
the alt-right has effectively used the
Internet to seize the high grounds of
sort of meme territory and then use it
as a way to spread the word so I have a
brief story about this that I think is
worth telling so I was speaking at a
California college last year and this
California College was you know a lot of
the conservatives had decided to ask me
there and we go to dinner afterward
which is one of the things that I tend
to do with the college Republican groups
that I that I get invited by so we were
sitting there having a good time we're
talking and one of the guys pipes up and
says that they just found a Milo and I
said that's great
you know whatever you know that's that's
fine and and he is at the end of the
dinner he waits till the end of dinner
and everybody is filing out the door and
this fellow turns to me and he said any
kind of winked at me
quietly he's wearing a mag a hat and
went to me quietly and he says another
show on okay for people don't know that
means another show is one of these
alt-right anti-semitic memes suggesting
that all jews do is talk about the
Holocaust all day long
right that everything is another show I
show us it works a Holocaust and they
don't say another they say another right
a and udda H not a show up because
you're stupid you keep talking about the
Holocaust you terrible Jews and the guys
looked at me and said this and he
obviously meant it as like a wink wink
nod nod joke and I just thought to
myself why would you think that that's
okay I'm not going to like ruin your
life over it I don't think your life
ought to be ruined over but why would
you think that that's okay because the
joke is not you know mocking
anti-semitism the joke is actually
anti-semitic whereas the joke itself is
actually anti-semitic like I'm on steven
crowder show a lot and Stevens a great
guy and Steven makes a lot of you know
jokes about Jews right he'll talk about
how my he doesn't like the fact that we
have this beautiful tumblr because he
has his own mug club until make a joke
about hard tumblr stinks but we filled
it with Google's right the whole point
of him doing that is not because he's
actually a medic the point is he's
mocking himself for pretending to be
anti-semitic that's the point of the
joke well point of the joke is that
anti-semitism stupid that's the entire
point of the joke that's why when Steven
doesn't it's not offensive the point of
the another Shoah means is not that
anti-semitism is stupid it's not self
parenting right it's that the Jews
actually there's something nefarious
about the Jews like it is an answer
somatic joke this stuff is being passed
around by people who don't know about
our I don't think akin was an
anti-semite I think the kid was
perfectly nice kid I think the kid was
being dragged into this meme under
culture where being frivolous and trolli
is seen as a positive good because
anything that pisses off sjw's anything
where people are triggered means it's a
good thing and so this idea that if you
trigger people that's a good thing
people sided with Trump because they
felt like he triggered people ticking
off the left is more important than
being decent or being right and that's
really a negative thing this is how
people get sucked into the mob they all
right
not because they start off as white
supremacists but because they believe
that anything that trolls left must
inherently be decent or good it's a
dangerous dangerous thing okay and again
not everybody who loves memes is is a
member of the alt-right and vast
majority people who like memes are not
members of the alright but this is how
the outright recruits is how the
alt-right seduces they say it's they say
we're just being dissidents and trolling
and we're tweeting out anti-semitic and
racist memes and it's because the left
can't take a joke that they don't like
your stuff not because they don't like
racism or anti-semitism but because they
can't take a joke and then that is not
positive in any way and the right needs
to excise that and president Trump
please for the love of God stop
associating with people from the
allright and retweeting them I
understand you think that a solid part
of your base I understand maybe Steve
Bannon has told you there a part of your
base you can't afford to alienate or the
President of the United States for God's
sake you represent the entire country be
a man and reject these groups stop
retweeting them stop reaching out to
them these are not people you want to be
associated with these are not people who
are winning the meme allure for you he
didn't win the election because of the
meme war
I understand the alt-right likes to say
that you won because of the me more
memes are funny memes are wonderful you
didn't win because of the meme or you
won because Hillary Clinton was the
worst candidate in the history of
mankind and I want to get to the the
media then and how they've reacted to
all this and what I thought was an
egregious segment on CNN yesterday plus
it we have things I like things I hate
then deconstructing the culture but
before we get to any of that person I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at my Patriot supply so right now
obviously things feel very chaotic a
North Korea continues to be a global
threat Russia continues to be a global
threat al Qaeda and Isis continue to be
threat and beyond that you have natural
disasters this is why you need my
Patriot supply you need survival food
supply for $99 it includes 102 servings
and breakfast lunches and dinners for
less than a dollar per serving listen
even the government says you ought to
have on hand some food that you can make
sure that you have in case of an
emergency because the government can't
always get to you and you shouldn't rely
on them and the grocery stores aren't
always restock that's why you need
survival food supply for 99 bucks 102
servings of breakfast lunches and
dinners order now eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 or online and
prepare with been calm that's prepared
with Ben's economics is 99 bucks plus
free shipping my paper hood supply
believes in old-fashioned values and
good people I know them go over to
prepare with Ben comm 8 8 8 803 1413
folks at the office have tried the food
they say that it tastes like home
cooking again it is my Patriot supply
prepare with Ben comprehend calm ok so
last night on CNN but the media have
decided that the part of the problem
here is the media likes the ratings they
get off of all this stuff I mean there
is part of the media that that is
overjoyed when this sort of stuff
happens because the controversy drives
ratings and the left is eager
always to label everyone as I say a
member of the alt-right no matter
whether they're a member of the
alt-right or not and last night on CNN
this panel just devolved because there
was a Trump fan in Paris Denard who was
a bush staffer and Keith Boykin who's a
Democratic staffer and in Boykin just
goes directly after Denard and basically
says he's not black I'm offended that
you continue to go there Paris but the
reality is that President Trump has not
done enough and I'm ashamed that you as
an African American Paris will not say
that well truth I don't need you to talk
about my black card I am well aware of
my blackness and don't need you to try
to classify me as being one I understand
what race are you i teeth don't go there
do not go there I know what it means to
be a black man in this country I know
and I experience racism on a regular
basis by being a trump supporter and by
being a proud American who happens to be
a Republican I give up making us earn
your business i get racist i got rivers
i'm in about nine and family about my
mother about my girlfriend about my
character we every single day remotely
coming world black nerd or even if you
really want to get down to it i'm from
my family from georgia Keith let me
finish my family from Georgia we have
members of our family that went missing
because of the KKK taking them up so
don't come to me and tell me about what
it is be a black person in this country
I fought every day and the George Tenet
is why our house I have to eat that meat
in it calm down no no I won't calm down
because I will not be attacked by you
about my blackness because I happen to
be a Republican and I listen to our
president when you want to is going off
the rails here I going on on Israel okay
so the fact is that para cenar has every
reason to lash out to keep Boykin for
what Keith Boykin just said but this is
the sort of stuff the media loves to
promulgate and it's just pushing the
conflict to a higher and higher pitch
none of this is good all of it is
frightening okay time for some things I
like things I hate in them will
deconstruct some culture but first but
first you're going to have to go over to
Daley wire and become a subscriber from
$9.99 a month you can see our show it is
not just an audio show it is a visual
show in all of its massive glory now you
can see it $4.99 a month you can be part
of the mailbag which we do on Friday
you can see the show live plus we've
post the show again later at daily
wire.com you can see the show without
any of the ads so you can do that as
well tailee wired.com $9.99 a month if
you want the annual subscription that
you get this the very greatest of all
tumblers hated by steven crowder beloved
by the public left this year's hot or
cold it is it is a glorious glorious
piece of hardware that you will treasure
all your life hand down to your
descendants and finally one day when
when when future civilizations look back
and say what did they produce they'll
realize the only thing we produces is
left this year's hot or cold mug that
was worthwhile keeping so make sure that
you get one of those for $99 a year you
can get that plus all of the other
things I just talked about you get
Knowles's show which is coming up at
1:30 today and you can get Andrew Clavin
the show which is coming up at 10:30
today we have a full slate of
programming here at the daily wired you
get all of it by going over to daily
wire and subscribing plus go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud right now please go
over to iTunes and subscribe we continue
to be ranked extraordinarily highly on
iTunes leave a review when you subscribe
and leave a review it helps us with our
rankings also make sure that you go over
to SoundCloud and give us a listen as
well we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so four things I like today I want
to do an oldie but a goodie because it's
it's I think almost indicative of where
we've gone as a country these two books
that I'm about to talk about so Harper
Lee wrote one of the great American
classics of course To Kill a Mockingbird
and it is a phenomenal book it is a
truly phenomenal book I remember reading
this book I think I was probably nine
when I read To Kill a Mockingbird for
the first time and it is a brilliant
beautifully written piece about the
power of not only tolerance but fighting
for fighting for the right it's just
it's just terrific the movie itself is
also very good you'll spot a very young
Robert Duvall is Boo Radley actually in
the movie he's in it for five seconds
but to Kill a Mockingbird by Harper Lee
just a grand grand book the whole book
about is really an ode to to scout is
the main character her father Atticus
Finch then Atticus Finch of course one
of the great American literary heroes is
a lawyer who defends an innocent black
man accused of a crime and it's it's all
about what it takes in what what heroism
requires and sometimes it's quiet and
sometimes it just requires standing up
for the right things but what I was
going to say is that it demonstrates
where we've gone into countries in the
last couple of years in an attempt to
make some profit the there is another
version of this book that Harper Lee
wrote that was never published right it
was originally written in the mid-1950s
and it was the first novel that Harper
submitted publishers and was rejected
it's called go set a watchman and it
features a lot of the characters from
tequila Mockingbird some twenty years
later and it's about scout realizing
that her dad was actually a racist and
her dad was actually not so nice and all
this kind of stuff and this is the
monster of the fact that To Kill a
Mockingbird is about the American dream
and how we need more Americans like
Atticus Finch in order to achieve the
American dream and go set a watchman is
about how the American Dream doesn't
really exist even the people who you
think are heroes are actually villains
we have to get away from go set a
watchman and back to to kill a
mockingbird we all need to be idolizing
Atticus Finch we all need to be moving
in that direction and we need to get
away from the world where everyone's a
villain so if Atticus Finch is a villain
we all might as well be villains you
know the sort of sullying of the Atticus
Finch character and go to Watchmen is
really one of the literary tragedies of
the last ten years and it's um you
should read the original and ignore the
rewriting in go set a watchman that was
only released
for profit after Harper Lee was unclear
whether Harper Lee was even competent to
release it apparently
but the tequila Mockingbird is is again
one of my favorite novels okay time for
some things that I hate so I haven't
talked to Jeff and I think that it is
and I think that worth while noticing a
couple of things so we'll start with
dennis prager so Dennis preggers friend
of mine and in Dennis was almost
rejected from conducting with the Santa
Monica Symphony Orchestra a Walt Disney
Concert Hall the left tried to destroy
Dennis they tried to suggest that Dennis
was a racist and a sexist and a bigot
and a homophobe and therefore he
shouldn't be allowed to conduct the
Santa Monica Symphony at Walt Disney
Concert Hall about 2300 seats and he was
he was pushed not to conduct the
heightened Symphony number 51 there were
two UCLA professors and in Michael Chiu
and Andrew after they're both violinist
with the Santa Monica Symphony and they
wrote in an open letter please urge your
friends to not attend this concert which
helps normalize bigotry and our
community Prager is a right-wing radio
host who promotes horribly bigoted
positions Dennis does not promote
horribly bigoted positions of course
it's just another demonstration the left
attempts to lump everyone in with the
alt-right and that's why it is so
important both at the left stop doing
that and at the right actively separate
itself from the all right and from the
racists who would hang around the
fringes and pretend to be important
members of the movement this stuff is
not justifiable and Dennis Dennis
is one of the good guys and the idea
that Disney Hall should have been closed
to to Dennis just demonstrates the
intolerance of the left it's it's quite
ridiculous so it didn't work the New
York Times wrote an article on the issue
The Hollywood Reporter wrote an article
on the issue and it just shows that when
the right stands up and says we're not
going to stand for being called racist
sexist biggest homophobes when we're not
then people back down but in order for
that to work you actually have to not
associate with racist sexist bigots and
homophobes which of course the vast
majority of people who are conservative
don't the Allred is not a conservative
movement it's an anti conservative
movement and pretending that they're
just a trolli version of the
Conservatives is really not true it's a
bad that it's bad definitionally okay
other things that I hate so the
Washington Post's trying to hit the
Trump campaign yesterday and it's just
amazing the way that the Washington Post
tries to get away with hitting Trump
even when it's unjustified so the
Washington
host had an article titled Trump
campaign emails show aids repeated
efforts to set up Russia's meetings okay
from that headline you would gathered
that someone in the Trump campaign was
actively attempting to set up meetings
with the Russians with the with the
oversight of the Trump campaign but the
article itself says in paragraph three
the proposal sends a ripple of concern
through campaign headquarters in Trump
Tower campaign co-chairman Sam Clovis
wrote that he thought NATO ally should
be consulted before any plans were made
another Trump adviser cited legal
concerns including a possible violation
of US sanctions okay and that so in
other words the documents show that
Trump tried to fight back right it from
the Trump campaign tried to fight back
against this this particular efforts to
set up some sort of meeting with the
Russians so sort of undercuts the the
Russian narrative that's not what the
headline says just another example of
the media blowing up a story that really
is an exculpatory story for Trump into
something that is not exculpatory okay
final thing that I hate and it'll
deconstruct a little bit of culture the
final thing that I hate here is again
just showing that the left has no clue
what they're doing and they're actually
pushing more people into the arms of the
alright this is from the New York Times
after a day of work at the engineering
Research Center at University of
Arkansas Kyle Quinn had a pleasant
Friday night in bentonville with his
wife and a colleague explored an art
exhibition and Crystal Bridges Museum of
American Art and dined in an upscale
restaurant then on Saturday he
discovered that social medias wootz had
incorrectly identified him as a
participants in a white nationalist
rally some 1,100 miles away in
Charlottesville
over night thousands of strangers across
the country have been working to share
photographs of men Darren tiki torches
on the University of Virginia campus but
he were there was a guy at the rally
who's photographed wearing an Arkansas
engineering shirt and amateur
investigators found a photo of Quinn
that looked something something similar
and that was enough to go after Quinn
and they basically ruined his life
people demanded he lose his job people
accused him of racism people posted his
home address on social networks he and
his wife stayed with a colleague this
weekend okay again that the fever pitch
in this country it needs to it needs to
calm down this is insanity
he can't target innocent people because
you're attempting to get the guilty this
is just nuts folks ok the sort of daxing
of people it has to stop it has to
stop just Wow Wow okay time to
deconstruct the culture a little bit so
one of the things that I hate about the
modern pop culture is the attempt to
virtually signal we talked about this in
recent weeks affair but the cultural
figures who feel the need to virtue
signal on politics because they think
that it's going to make them more pop
culturally the sort of popular that is
going to is going to draw more support
it's really it's really foolish so one
of the people who's doing this was of
course Lord Lord not like God lor D the
e the young New Zealand singer Lorde was
she wanted Royals is that her group okay
yeah so she a she did the song Royals
she's like a one-hit wonder I'm not sure
she's ever done anything else but she's
done saying she's done some other stuff
okay Mathis is more with it than I am
he's a decade younger than I am so he's
still ensconced in this in this idiotic
culture so Lord a lordy Lord alo tardy
she she tweeted out being a privileged
white non-us citizen I feel like
tweeting to reinforce how horrific
people of color treatment here is is
unnecessary and inappropriate okay and
then she says I just want to say I'm so
so sorry all white people are
responsible for this systems thrive and
fall we have to do better I'm sorry
who is we I didn't do any of these
things and I think all the people who
did these things are despicable and I've
spent my career fighting these people so
who is we like that you wonder why
there's an identity politics of the
right maybe that is because there's an
anti white identity politics you know
the white identity politics a lot of
that the growth of that is a direct
response to the identity politics of the
left would suggest that the color of
your skin makes you responsible for the
sins of other white people I am NOT
responsible
pretty sin committed by a white person
just because I am white you are not
responsible for the sin of a black
person just because you are black this
insanity that suggests that race confers
guilt or innocence upon you that
ethnicity confers guilt or innocence
upon you it's just that it's insanity
and the virtue signaling by pop cultural
figures for attempting to make it clear
to their audience just how woke they are
the Katy Perry looking like she came
back from college as a lesbian dance
theory major and sitting with DeRay
McKesson cross-legged on the couch
talking about her cultural
responsibility look if you didn't do
anything wrong
we live in an individual culture okay I
don't believe in social in social
justice because I believe in
justise if you didn't do anything wrong
you are not guilty if I didn't do
anything wrong
I am not guilty if you did do something
wrong you are guilty and if I did
something wrong I am guilty otherwise no
guilt no innocence okay your moral
status is neutral if you haven't done
anything you do have a duty to come out
and condemn racism when you see it as a
moral human being but that does not make
you complicit when in racism if you do
the right thing doing the right thing is
you doing the right thing I mean I don't
know when we why is it that we have to
do like third grade morality for people
again this is insane okay other things
that I hate in the culture so I've been
lamenting the politicization of sports
for for several years now particularly
over at ESPN one of the shows that I
used to enjoy watching a lot more on
ESPN was pardon the introduction with
Tony Kornheiser and Michael Wilbon
they're both really clever guys they
know a lot about sports I used to be a
big fan of the show but now it seems
like it's just two lefties going back at
each other on every topic Under the Sun
and that's really boring it's really
boring ESPN has made a huge mistake by
attempting to excise everyone who has a
different point of view people like Curt
Schilling people like Mike Ditka people
like Chris Broussard you know all these
people been marginalized or thrown out
because they have conservative points of
view and so you end up with stuff like
this on ESPN again sports fans tend to
be overwhelmingly conservative actually
the majority of sports fans particularly
NFL fans for example are our
conservative most most NFL fans by the
polls the ones I've seen say that
they're conservative but nonetheless you
have situations like ESPN's Tony
Kornheiser saying that we should just
stop playing the national anthem at
sporting events altogether I think it's
a lot and I worry that maybe I say it so
much that people pay no attention
anymore this is a constitutional right
this is a guaranteed thing if you don't
want to stand for the anthem you don't
have to a lot of times I say it in half
jest but I'm getting to the point where
it's not even half just anymore I don't
even know why they've lady anthem I
think I'll play the Beach Boys I like
the beach I would me personally and I
think you two I would stand for the
answer yeah what if you don't it's like
not some troublesome to me if you don't
do this okay why is okay so it should be
troublesome when people don't stand for
our common anthem because there's one
thing you should hope is that the anthem
comes to embody what you want it to
embody a suggesting that America is
thoroughgoing race as racist is nonsense
of course
Kaepernick and everybody else is
kneeling for the anthem has the right to
kneel for the anthem it's America you
get to do what you want but the idea
that we should stop playing the anthem
at all - so as not to offend the
delicate sensibilities and people who
don't like the flag what a bunch of
horse manure really silly stuff okay
other the other politicized topic of the
week it's all been Kaepernick all the
time over at ESPN I mean it's amazing
how many people seem to care deeply
about a second-string quarterback who
absolutely blows at his job for the last
two years but Steven Naismith says that
Charlottesville should get Kaepernick a
job it's amazing how the outcome is
always Kaepernick should have a job and
it's like car crash in in Louisiana
Kaepernick should get a job storm clouds
roll over Texas Kaepernick should get a
job doesn't matter what a is B is always
Kaepernick should get a job
here's Steven Naismith sayin
Charlottesville should be the reason
Kaepernick gets a job or something for
no reason whatever now in light of what
occurred this weekend in Charlottesville
Steve Nate will this change opinions on
Colin well first of all it should I
think to some degree it has and I want
to state for the record that damn sure
had better change the opinions of owners
within the National Football League
quick fast and then a hurry
not just quick not just fast but quick
fast and in a hurry
also expediently speedily as fast as
their little legs could carry them okay
why what does Charlotte still have to do
with Colin Kaepernick let's Colin
Kaepernick there did I miss it
what a child is that what well it to
suggest that the NFL owners are like
Richard Spencer is just insane it's just
insane you have any evidence of that
whatsoever there Bob Kraft is like
Richard Spencer what absolute nonsense
but again the sort of politicization
drives people to the all right
okay drives people to the extremes
whenever you have politicization of what
our common topics it drives people
insane and transcends the extremes of
politics it's a bad thing
we should have social fabric or we can
come together the national anthem seems
like one place we should be able to come
together watching football games seems
like another place we should come
together if even these last tiny and
almost insignificant vestiges of
commonality are ripped away from us and
it's pretty clear that that we are going
to be irrevocably torn in the near
future okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with more updates on all the latest on
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]